frustrated drivers waiting for the
widening of a busy street in the far
southwest valley are going to have to
wait just a little bit longer traffic
anchor nate tannebaum has the update
round two of that road expansion
blasting on ford apache south of warm
springs it's been delayed supposed to be
yesterday now in case you missed round
one here's how that went last friday
around noon
[Applause]
and one more time
[Applause]
yeah so they're taking out part of the
mountain there for the expansion when
it's finished the widening of fort
apache is going to reach all the way
down from warm springs to huntington
cove parkway about half mile north of
wigwam so whenever they do that next
round ford apache will be closed drivers
will be detuned over to durango as they
say on tv stay tuned for more
information on this developing story
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone someone's driving you
crazy email me traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com
okay this has been written for me by the
way
nate has deputized me as a junior
traffic buddy to bring you this breaking
blasting update
clark county has now scheduled the
second round of dynamite blasting on
fort apache it's going to happen friday
at noon so if you have any questions you
can look for that story on our website
at 8newsnow.com
then you can click traffic and driving
you crazy i've been deputized little
junior traffic buddy
thanks junior traffic buddy